let me set the table for our viewers
Russell you are in London right now as I
correct I'm in the countryside outside
of London where some years ago I escaped
to to bucolic bliss to have a family and
to explore different states of
consciousness without chemicals very
nice and how's that working for you
I miss the chemicals a nice London
you're married now and you have children
is that right yeah I've got two children
and I didn't know how much feces would
be involved Conan yes they they tend to
do that
yes very grounding isn't it well yes I
have two children but they're older now
they're teenagers and they're still
quite a lot of feces I'll be honest with
you mm-hmm
that's Ann happens well into adulthood
I'm looking forward to at least a decade
and a half of excretion okay well listen
here's what I want to get to Russell
when I first met you you were a wild man
you wore tight leather pants you prowled
the streets like a lion
you were very sexually active and in
fact you talked very frankly about your
sex addiction and now look at you
wrapped like a saint
in white blankets in bucolic bliss in
the countryside with the wife and
children what was that transition light
in a way it's a cliched journey isn't it
from excess to conversion and to the
embrace of the spiritual life but what I
was told is that all of these energies
we put into drugs and promiscuity are
yearning for a kind of wholeness a
connection to the limitless access to
the sacred and the divine if you can't
get those things simply acquire yourself
a blanket and wait the time to pass you
know I read that once on a box of herbal
tea it sounds like a cliche but it's
just true the there's a hole in all of
us that makes
see that's probably why you and I got
into comedy isn't it yes I think
initially I was drawn to committee for
approval for the the possibility of of
orgasm primarily you not on stage you
didn't want to have the orgasm on stage
did you you just meant that comedy would
lead you towards the opposite sex and
then there'd probably be an orgasm how I
mean I wonder how many of human
endeavors from a manned space flight to
the advent of the spinning jenny in in
Victorian London do you think were
ultimately motivated by the need for
that kind of fulfillment that manner of
fulfillment Russell I agree I think the
Wright brothers built that plane just to
get laid I really do I think they wanted
to fly to a nearby farm impress the
ladies with their flying machine and
then Wilbur and Orville we're gonna get
it on with some of the local ladies I
think he would explain to will Wilbur
and Orville this in your case will not
lead to sexual opportunity just being an
answer in Trivial Pursuit and
disappointment maybe they wouldn't have
bothered you know yeah yeah maybe they
wouldn't have built the plane we
wouldn't have an airplane now if it
wasn't for a human need for sex right it
could be seen as the drive behind many
many things but I suppose my point
though Conan and I'll sweep my blanket
behind my ear to make it very maintained
I've been maintaining this myself since
high school this I get up in the morning
and it takes very little work a little
mayonnaise a baker's kill about 45
minutes at 600 degrees and look it's
done look at that
what an incredible scalp that you've got
there and I must say that for you to
maintain those standards I didn't
this would be something that you'd be
able to sustain during the lockdown I
thought the first thing to go would be
the altitude of your quiff this is my
way of supporting the world this is my
way of showing that we cannot give up we
cannot give in this is my statement your
hair follicles are like the Ravens in
the tower at the Tower of London as long
as your hair follicles are upright we
are okay yeah like Churchill's cigar was
a mighty phallic symbol a sort of
tobacco penis in the face of Nazi
Germany your hair that magnificent
Auburn edifice is a hole that will
protect us if not from the virus itself
then certainly from the dispiriting
effect of the virus you know Russell
that's that's so kind but I do think you
hit the nail on the head my quiff as you
call it my pompadour this massive
Belgian pastry that I wear on my head is
my defiance it is my way of saying stand
back virus you shall not pass ya know
pass another they say yeah well done I
mean it's like a hinge I think in
generations to come druids may gather
round what remains of that glorious
[Laughter]